there are currently 8 billion people on
Earth uh Earth's not overcrowded despite
what they say that there is in fact
plenty of room for everybody vast swaths
of of the globe are still basically
uninhabited and that includes many
thousands of square miles of land that
that could be inhabited so I'm not just
talking about like Antarctica here the
world is not overcrowded it's not
overpopulated certain parts of the world
you know can become overcrowded and
overpopulated uh so like if you Tred to
fit everyone on earth into United States
of America well yes now you've got a
real crowding overpopulation problem
because you've crammed everybody in I'll
be dead soon that's a you problem